it was a night of some far-left ideas
and that didn't stop when it came to the
topic of immigration with some of the
candidates II mean to basically endorse
open borders I would follow that up in
my first hundred days with immigration
reform that were onerous island claims
that would put undocumented immigrants
as long as they haven't committed a
serious crime on a pathway to
citizenship my plan also includes
getting read rid of section 1325 of the
Immigration and Nationality Act
criminalizes coming across the border we
would not detain any family fleeing
violence and then we would rewrite our
immigration laws in our own image free
dreamers forever from any fear of
deportation by making them US citizens
here in this country that the separation
of children from families doesn't just
go on at our border it happens in our
community is this ice or ripping away
parents from their American children
spouses in the light and are creating
fear in cities all across this country
where parents are afraid to even drop
their kids off to school or go to work
we must defend those policies but at
least one Democrat seems to be
retreating here's who leon castro i'm
for decriminalizing not legalizing there
are still civil penalties people are
still part of a court process people are
still subject to the laws of the United
States they still go through a process
also open borders is a right wing
talking point we have 654 miles of
fencing we have thousands of border
personnel we have planes we have
helicopters we have boats we have guns
we have security cameras nobody has
called for open borders Jesse what do
you think of that I mean they have bado
said he doesn't want a wall I mean Trump
wants to issue deportation and they want
to issue invitation that's what their
policies add up to that's what they're
all about they wanted to pull back
Border Patrol from the front lines they
don't want to fund the Border Patrol
they want to put a cap on the beds and
the detention facilities and they're not
doing anything to stop the influx all
they're doing is when they get here they
want to catch and release so that's open
borders it's enough said I think what
the problem is with the Democrats is
that they've now gone so far on
immigration they've gone so far on
taxing and spending and then ripping
private health care away and
operations it's the most radical
progressive crop of candidates you've
ever seen and what happened with
President Obama when he went so far left
so much change in such a short period of
time he got shellacked so hard at the
end of his term the Democrats were out
of power so far since they hadn't been
in 1920 the American people can't handle
all that radical change that quickly and
this crop of Democrats is doing it twice
as fast and twice as crazy and it's
really gonna hurt them but wait a second
Jesse I mean just this very day
you see Nancy Pelosi saying oh yeah okay
I'll go on cuz the children come first
and we want to make sure that there is
not abuse of these children in these
horrible situation down at the border so
don't Democrats get credit what took her
for months what took her for months what
about the guy who said we have an
invasion that we need to send the
military we need to build a wall do you
think there's a reason that Democrats
might say you know what you're not
sincere about helping anybody you're
playing politics you're immigrant okay
so there is a crisis now there's a
humanitarian issue with special issue
it's not a terrorist attack that's like
workplace violence all know what I'm
saying to you so yesterday when you
listen to Julian Castro and I think he's
right this is a Republican talking point
we have nobody's calling for open
borders but you do have a problem in
terms of this zero-tolerance policy
about metering asylum claims now even
the officers who represent the folks who
do asylum are suing the government
joining with the ACLU to say the remain
in Mexico policy is not good not in
keeping with us values not in making
them and their job easier more efficient
so Tim you closed the asylum loophole
one and you treat the Central American
migrants the same way you treat the
Mexicans
keep them that's it respectful so you
don't have to catch a babe just saying
obey the law the law right now as stands
and enforce the law better or work in
the debate he said we would not detain
anyone that has fleeing violence mm-hmm
well that's all of them yeah the thing
is they have they have no process they
have no system
they have wishes but they can't explain
what to do you know who we know who
caused the children crisis it was
activists who egged on the caravans
remember where this started it was the
c-word the caravans which caused us to
react if we had actually if the
Democrats if the Congress had listened
to Trump a child would be alive that
died because he was talking about
preventing this from happening when you
have thousands and thousands of people
coming when you have a large movement of
people coming there are risks people
will get hurt people will die it happens
and it's terrible it wouldn't have
happened if you had actually addressed
the problem when all of us were talking
about the problem but the point is these
politicians are too scared to address
this problem
because of the activist consensus media
you know they it's a trump will nail
this in a debate if he says who do you
want to do do you want to decide our
immigration policy other countries or us
that's the simplest question and the
Dems Democrats can't decide on that
question the same way they can't decide
on homelessness or they can't decide on
law and order think about it it's not
the victim it's always the criminal it's
not the store owner it's always the guy
loitering in front of the store it's not
the citizen who decides immigration it's
the other countries in each one of these
situations the Democrats never pick the
right side and never have a process I
just I just let me quickly respond and
say I think we picked the right size
because American values are we're a
country of immigrants we were possible
and after World War two when we realized
that we had kept out Jewish people
fleeing the Germans we said you know
what we're gonna change I'm gonna put
while we've been on air in during this
block the house has passed the Senate
bill this is for the emergency money
that the administration has asked for
for the last few months and I think that
politically as one of what you think
about the Democrats they want to go on
their recess and they didn't want to
have to go to recess and not have all
this dealt with because the tide was
turning on the narrative I hate that
word but the storyline was going to
follow them that they were blocking
resources to help take care of these
kids better life that never should have
happened months ago and I want the
Democrats to step up and talk about why
all these people are trying to pour into
the United States
it's because the economy is so strong
quite frankly that you have in terms of
job openings in this country you have a
record number a difference we need job
openings and unemployed in this nation
it's about 1.6 2 million more jobs
available here and the strange thing
about all these Democratic policies is
it's gonna drive the economy into a
recession if one of them got elected and
that means that it would actually slow
immigration and you know in the corrupt
Central American countries don't spend
any money on welfare on housing on
health care they push all their poor
people north and that's several of their
game plan and decriminalizing basically
is the same thing as legalizing so you
mean it's an open you they I don't think
Mexicans are coming across the border
increasing numbers it's these Central
Americans and the reason they're fleeing
is because of the terrible economy but
also violence and oppression that's the
reason the problem we're at is well
again